good also in the wet also please if you
look back on your time as a function
what did you do right i made some
mistakes because i i imagine you
can listen carefully i
didn't hear everything sometimes didn't want to hear but there
have been many successes also defeat
that is  just the young chaplain say
success everything we've done in terms of reforming
the economic and
monetary union peter doesn't go far enough
things like that i don't think
i'll give up my office i'm relieved
but don't ask you have
got good advice from me
but  publicly presented
deductions are more deductions from says yes that was
the 100000 and 40
because I determined long that is enough
so figured
applied for we were there may heartily
denied only a large European
n450 meeting of the respective Council of Ministers
because the already impression of Linde shows
that in the  city ​​ca
n't do that too well for what is actually
popular in europe  to those because the
judges must have liked a lot encouraged
us we only hear 15
[music]